hello everyone welcome to a video on
code tekken tutorials today we're going
to talk about our lord and savior
see make what you think i was going to
say
if you're a fan of this channel you
might know that i talk about c plus and
libraries and kind of project setups and
been trying to find the best practice
for that for years well ever since i
started programming and i recently
discovered that
they're just flat out it isn't any
there's nothing there's no
standard there's no best practice
there's a best
practice for a certain person or
institution it's a thing that they
usually do
but it doesn't really correlate with
necessarily the best way for you to do
it so you can't go online and just read
about
oh yeah here's what everybody does it's
uh here's what some people do
here's what other people do here's what
other people do and now here i am saying
hey look
i've been doing this for a long time and
uh
i think this is my favorite way to do it
it's a little confusing at first but
once you get used to it it's pretty good
so i learned back in the day with make
files
so if you don't know what a make file is
it is just a file called a make file and
it runs commands so at the top it'll
have
like a default and it'll say something
that runs in bash
like uh usually it'll be like g plus
plus um
your main.cpp and the out is whatever
you want it to be
make files are what cmake turns into
basically cmake makes your make file
which sounds confusing and weird to say
but that's basically how it goes down
so i'm saving this file i guess i'm
gonna
real quick i'm just gonna go into my
projects and make a new folder
i'm just gonna make a new folder for
this there's a new folder button that's
right here sure i could go into command
line and do make dir
and all that stuff but it's right here
so we're just gonna call this
uh our lord
and savior now anyone who searches my
computer sees my folders is gonna think
i'm
some kind of fundamental christian but
you know
whatever so we're going to name this
file oops let's do a search now
make file
and you can do it with a capital m too
that's fine
so we save it all right so now
that we have the make file the makefile
runs which is the make command so i open
my terminal here
and we're gonna go cd into my projects
and then
our lords and savior that's gonna be
funny to say maybe i'll actually put
this repo up just to
troll github a little bit that'll be
that'd be fun all right so let's see
what we got in here with a little bit of
look and we just got to make files so if
we type make
well it's uh it's a little confused it
says missing separator
that's because make fire make files do
not accept spaces and as you can see i
got spaces here so what i actually need
is this to be a tab so i just
highlighted them all and press tab and
there it
tells me there's a tab that's just a
feature of this editor
and a new line there all right so now
that we
we save that we go back into our command
line and we type make
and it tries to do the thing of course
it doesn't see the make doesn't or
doesn't see the main so it's just like i
don't i don't have that
but if for example i just made one
no hey i got it i got it i got what
we're gonna do
hey zeus
yeah get it get it all right
and of course we'll name this main.cpp
we should obviously return a
zero or something yeah i don't i don't
care about syntax
it's just an example of how to basically
use a make file and why do you need to
know this why am i showing this in a
tutorial about cmake because this is
like
the entire thing that cmake does so if
you don't know this
it's just like it's like missing your
roots when you're a tree
so you have to understand the very
basics of a make file
is all it does is
is just run whatever command you tell it
to
and it's really really a linux thing so
windows has their own way of handling
cmake
for their builds for visual studio or
whatever compiler you're using and you
can you can get linux support on windows
too so this can be
exactly relevant to windows just depends
on how you're building
i can do a video on the windows version
of this if you want i just
started up this one because it was easy
all right so we basically get our out
and we can
run her out of course dot slash and says
hey zeus
all right so that's make files got a
list of things over here
right here yeah if you think of anything
else that should go in the next video
let me know so i'm going to basically
tell you how to get your project started
i'm going to talk about levels and
projects mainly
and we'll see if i have time for
variables and lives but that might have
to be
next video so i'm going to continue this
and try to cover
everything in cmake with this one
so cmake relies on a top level file
called see make lists dot
txt it has to be exactly like that has
to be capital c
capital m capital l and list plural and
dot txt
has to be exactly that so i'm just going
to use the linux command touch
to create this file right now and now if
i look at my directory i'll see
that it exists right here along with my
other files that i made earlier
i'm just going to remove the other files
because i don't need them
make file and out goodbye
all right so now that we have our cmake
file
we can run cmake and basically to run
cmake
you need to tell it where your source is
where your build folder is and
you can make your build folder where
sources but please don't
but just just know some projects do that
and i think it annoys some people but
once again like i said at the beginning
of this video
there is no standard for this either and
there's some standard for the install
we'll get to that way later about how to
install with cmake because cmake can do
everything everything you can think of
that you want to do for your project
it can do you want a nice little
executable for
windows that has the install that you
used to see in for every other program
cmake can do that that's kind of the end
product
so we'll get to that probably at the end
but
it's cool and it can do a lot of other
things along the way that your project
wants like run all the tests for your
project
and things like that so we'll step by
into that way later for now let's stick
with the very roots i just i just want
to really sell this cmake thing
because i think it is like the only way
to go and if you're doing it some other
way
please just just do let's all do this
okay this is
this seems better and also don't take my
word for do your own research yada yada
don't think that i'm like
100 sold on anything because you know
i like to consider everything
so basically you type c make to call it
command and
of course it tells us the usage because
we didn't give any commands
you definitely need to at least do this
bottom one
you need to path to where you want to
build it and a path to your source
and it considers its current path from
where you run it
so what most people do is they make a
directory
called build
and that's where they build everything
i'm going to remove that real quick
uh okay i'm going to do a recursive
force build okay
so i'm going to move that real quick
because i do it slightly different
i call the folder out and then build
oh yeah i got to put a dash p in front
of that for it to build all of those
since there are multiple directories
and then what you do is you go into
your out folder and then build folders
so you basically just go
to the folder that you want to build in
well you don't have to because as you
saw up here
you could specify the path to it so it
needs to know where your source is so
you go cmake
dash s backer directory back another
directory and that that's where the root
level cmakelist.txt is actually
that's the important thing it needs to
know where that root one is where to
start
and we need to know our build path our
build path is where we currently already
are
so we just put a dot for that so there
we go
that'll say the root cmakelist.txt
is two directories back and we want to
build here
and this this is really the main thing
this is the one thing you need to know
if you know anything at all
is this right here the source and where
to build all the special options come
later if you need them
and there it goes and it's checking that
file and it generates
and spits it out so what we'll see in
our build
we'll see our cmic files our cma cache
cmake install and a make file
you don't touch any of these ever
because they're generated with cmake
instead you just edit your cmakelist.txt
so let's just look at that make file so
i'm just going to do a
cat make file
and here it is start from the top
see it has all sorts of stuff default
target
all phony default target and as you can
see
it's got this command like this like i
was doing with that makefile because
this is just a make file it just builds
it all out best based on your
cmakelist.txt
the only thing it knows about really is
where our source store is because we
told it and where the binary dir is
dirt directory i'm just getting used to
saying it that way
and there's all our stuff but as you can
see it doesn't
actually do any building of any program
there's no
gcc there's no call to anything it's
basically just got some root set up with
with that actually doesn't do much but
even so
i guess the point of that is even a
blank cmakelist.txt will function
but let's go actually make rcmake
list.text do its main thing so i'm going
to open up visual studio code here
on this directory and let's take a quick
look we got the cmakelist.txt
right here so at the top you make
cmake minimum required this is the
minimum version
of oh version here of cmake that you
require
and we'll just put like 3.10.2
and you can always check by going in
here and doing cmake i think it's just
dash dash
version and yeah i want 3.13.4 so a lot
of people say
you should use whatever you're currently
using as latest version
but if you know you're doing stuff
that's backwards compatible you can
make this older this doesn't matter a
whole lot you just have to have
something here basically
make it some version that you know will
work
so that's one thing that is required
here we're going to do a little
different this time this time when we
run
our cmake we're going to run it with the
source right where we are
and the build down a couple directories
like so so you can do it either way it
doesn't matter where you run cmake from
as long as you tell where the root cmake
file is
and you tell where the build is you're
good
and there it goes it generates it
there's nothing really new here
although then it's going to now probably
in there do some kind of check for that
in the cache or something
so still doesn't do much so generally
what you do on the top level one is you
do add
project call this uh our lord
and savior oh lass it'll be olas
and it crashes what is this
oh it's not i'm sorry it's i don't think
this is ad project i think it's just
projects
yeah there we go it's just project
okay and the next thing we need to do if
we wanted to actually build something
is we say i think this is add
executable and we'll give the executable
name
um hope not no less i think this is just
project name
we'll see i'll get an error if not but
it should translate into this
basically and i could even expand it out
and say
something else but it needs the source
next here and the source is main.cpp so
we want to build it into an object
called whatever this project name is
let's see if that's correct
yep looks good so now when we
run make which we can't because we're
not in that directory so we got to go to
the out
and then into the build and then once
we're in here we'll notice
that's where the make file is we could
look at the make file again just to see
what it has now
and we'll now see that it has some stuff
in here about that cpp file that we put
as the executable
okay well let's let's just try running
this makefile and see what happens
built target okay so now let's look
again see what we got
yeah the project name was correct so
yeah that is a correct thing to get your
project name anytime you want to
reference it so
you'll see this little operator all over
the place and it basically just
references a variable cmake saves a lot
of variables automatically
like your project name basically any of
these things you set
it's probably saved somewhere and you
can look up the documentation for
for more about those and i'll mention
them as i go you know the ones i use
but basically you can do this for a lot
of different things to reference names
that way you don't have to keep typing
the same note
name over and over and if i change this
name to something else then the project
name throughout the rest automatically
updates you know standard with variable
type stuff for programming
so cmake allows some of that special
stuff another cool thing about it as a
build system
okay well we've got a basic project set
up it does
run let me get this back up here
let's go ahead and run it
with the dot slash and of course says
the same thing that we already
programmed earlier
that's the very basics of getting cmake
started with just you know something
that executes
and that's going to do for this video i
will be covering more topics as we go
i didn't even get the levels really all
i got to got to was projects in the top
level
so really all i did was like top level
so i also want to talk about levels and
lives
to talk a little bit about variables but
i'll talk more about how to set
your own because you can set your own
variables and do do things with them
i'll show you some examples that get
into these things hopefully next video
i'll try my best to make it concise this
is a lot to explain and there's so many
different directions to go that's
actually quite hard to make it concise
that's one of the things i struggle with
on this channel and coding is the
many many many different directions i
could go and trying to decide
which is the best one to actually like
show because don't forget to hit like to
help support me and
anything else you want to do is much
appreciated i'll see you in the next
video
peace out goodbye see you next time on
oh god code wrecked and tutorials
uh see make
you know what you came here for you want
you want to learn
what's the best how do i stomp the
competition
with my build system